back into number 10 and here to stay
five more years for Boris Johnson and
the Conservatives a grueling campaign
for this prime minister and his team but
they've delivered an election win that
will take us out of Europe and reshape
Britain I am forming a new government
and on Monday MPs will arrive at
Westminster to form a new Parliament and
yes they will have an overwhelming
mandate from this election to get brexit
done and we will honor that mandate by
January the 31st after an ugly campaign
now an appeal to move on
I urge everyone to find closure and to
let the healing begin we are going to
unite and level up unite and level up
ringing together the whole of this
incredible United Kingdom England
Scotland Wales Northern Ireland together
this country deserves a break from
wrangling a break from politics and a
permanent break from talking about
brexit thank you all very much and happy
Christmas Thank You Horace Townsend the
most successful conservative Leominster
at the ballot box since Margaret
Thatcher he took a huge gamble on this
Christmas and lecture and it paid off
big time had he lost
he'd have ended up as the third shortest
serving prime minister in British
history as it is he's won a huge mandate
to transform our country extremely hard
tonight the scale of his victory
reflected in Labour's failure the
so-called red wall across Labour's
traditional heartlands demolished the
Conservative Party
19600 nine seat after seat fall into the
conservatives bulldozed by brexit this
the end for Jeremy Corbyn and his
political project - I did everything I
possibly could in order to bridge the
divide between those that voted leave
and those that voted remain because at
the end of the day they're going to live
in a country where we're going to need
that investment for the future we're
going to have if this government stays
in office more homelessness more
divisions and more a bigger gap between
the richest and the poorest and so I did
everything I could of course I take
responsibility for putting the manifesto
forward but I have to say the manifesto
was universally supported throughout our
party and throughout our movement he's
not the only political career cut short
have you lost your seat mr. Winston a
few weeks ago Joe Swinson said she could
be Prime Minister now she's lost her
seat and with it her job obviously it
hasn't worked and I like you I'm
devastated about that but I don't regret
trying elections are brutal but no
sympathy from the SMP their leader
euphoric that she took her rival out
tightening their grip on Scotland and
strengthened in their case for
independence so did the Prime Minister
let me be very clear this is not simply
a demand that I or the SNP are making it
is the rate of the people of Scotland
and you as the leader of a defeated
party in Scotland have no right to stand
in the way and in Northern Ireland - the
plates are shifting the dup x'
westminster leader cast aside in this
election for the first time ever this
nation has elected more nationalist MPs
the new unis for the first time in a
decade we've got no narrow majority no
coalition no minority government Boris
Johnson has won a big fat majority and
it's going to make that place behind me
much more managed
for him but he's got big challenges too
he's got just one year to turn his
slogan get brexit done into reality and
he's also got to figure out a way to
knit together his traditional Tory
voters in the Shires of England with his
new supporters in the industrial
heartland that have voted labour for
generations
and there are questions too about what
Boris Johnson's United Kingdom might
look like in five years time brexit will
happen but independence from the EU will
strain our union as Scotland and perhaps
Northern Ireland - bang the drum for
independence Boris Johnson's in power
and in number 10 but some things remain
out of his control
bethe Rigby Sky News Westminster